now denmark has temporarily halted the
use of the kovid-19 vaccine manufactured
by
astrazeneca that's after reports of a
small number of cases of blood clots
denmark only approved the astrazeneca
vaccine six days ago
for those above the age of 65. let's
bring in paul brennan who's in london
for us for more on this so paul any
reaction from oxford astrazeneca
to this decision by denmark to pose the
use of its vaccine
there hasn't been a reaction from
astrazeneca uh
yet uh i mean they said that they're in
contact with the austrian
authorities um because austria two
is uh stopping using the one particular
batch of astrazeneca
jabs astrazeneca vaccines after
uh two incidents there one was a death
from a coagulation disorder
and the other one was an illness from a
pulmonary embolism
so these are all sort of vaguely blood
clot related uh
things the danish situation appears to
be born of an abundance of caution
um because the danish health authority
has said that they haven't given any
details of exactly how many blood clot
cases there have been and they haven't
given any details of the background
history
of the one person who's died in denmark
but what they did say was that it was
currently not possible
not possible to conclude whether there
was a link between
the vaccine and these deaths so
the health minister said and i'm quoting
we are acting early
uh it needs to be thoroughly
investigated now
other countries appear to be suspending
their use
watching what's happening waiting for
the outcome of that it is a temporary
suspension for two weeks
other countries estonia lithuania
luxembourg and latvia
i'm also hearing that norway a line
that's just dropping is that norway
appears to be halting for the time being
its use of astrazeneca
um but astrazeneca issued a statement
uh earlier well yesterday actually
saying the safety of its faction had
been extensively studied and the vaccine
was generally well tolerated and and
the number of thromboembolic events as
it describes it
is no higher than that seen in the
general population so
it remains to be seen as to whether this
is sort of super
cautious uh behavior and action from
denmark and norway or whether it
actually is something that needs to be
more concerned with there have been
millions of these vaccines administered
22 million in excess
here in the uk alone more than three
million in the european union so to have
two cases in one country and two cases
in another with no firm link between
the vaccine and those cases does leave a
lot of questions still
unanswered paul elsewhere in europe
france is relaxing
uh restrictions on international
travelers
yeah i mean i mean the french
have really had a struggle uh with
coronavirus
and and they have been uh looking at uh
increasing numbers but uh
they are very keen of course with the
summer arriving to try to open up their
economy
um the other thing of course is germany
is uh is also facing the prospect of a
third wave and it's ironic perhaps that
while other countries are
sort of shutting down their vaccination
programs albeit temporarily norway
denmark
germany is screaming out for more
vaccines and trying to get more vaccines
into the arms of its uh of its citizens
so it is
you know it's curious it's it's a
indication i think of the
not exactly joined up thinking that is
taking place across
the european continent across the
european union with these different
countries taking very different
approaches
in relation to a open reopening
and b the vaccination programs
themselves
paul thank you very much for that paul
brennan live there in london well
let's discuss the safety of the
astrozenica vaccine
samoana with stereo moist jose
molecular biologist cindy associate
professor
in cellular and molecular sciences at
northumbria university he's
joining us from newcastle in the uk
thank you very much for being with us
so as we've heard concerns from denmark
about this astrazeneca
vaccine an investigation is underway
there austria has also suspended using
one batch of astrazeneca doses while it
investigates
death fare from coagulation disorders
first of all
can there be a link between blood clots
and a vaccine
well um there can be a potential link
claimed about anything and everything
right but
the uh the reality about these things is
in the absolute numbers
so whilst uh one cannot be 100 sure that
one batch of this vaccine might have
something wrong with it
it's entirely possible just like with
aspirin there might be one batch that
something's wrong with it
uh the reality is we need to see enough
of these
events in the population to be in a
in larger number than you would normally
expect
to be able to claim that actually
there's a specific direct link between
the two
um so if you think about the age groups
that are prioritized for vaccination
right now these are the
you know the elderly people generally
these are individuals who have
pre-existing conditions
and they're prone to strokes they're
prone to pulmonary embolisms that pour
into
heart attacks these things will happen
right so you would need to see
that you have much more of this
happening amongst those age groups
because these people are getting a
vaccine before you could safely say
ah it seems to be something the vaccine
so all the governments are doing the
correct thing right now
right just stopping checking to make
sure everything is okay so you don't
think they're overreacting these
countries no way also announcing now
that it's suspending its astrazeneca
19 vaccine rollout no i don't i don't
think that's an overreaction i think
it's an appropriate response there's
a concern that has been raised uh it
needs to be looked at
carefully independently and make sure
that those numbers
are uh interpreted accurately
for public safety whether that's
protecting people from the virus or
protecting people
uh from something that might have
happened with this batch of vaccine but
the likelihood
in general that the vaccine may have had
something untoward
is minimal the likelihood that a batch
of the vaccine may have something wrong
with it
is very small vanishingly small right
but as you know there's been concern
about the speed at which these vaccines
have been
developed what uh are some of the most
serious possible side effects associated
to these kovid 19 vaccines not just the
astrazeneca ones but the other ones that
are also
uh being rolled out right now
well that's the thing uh we keep
pandering this phrase all these things
are being developed too quickly
i would like to flip that coin and point
out to everybody
how fast we can develop things for
diseases we want to do
something about if we put the investment
and the time and the resources there
we are able to respond to diseases very
quickly that's how advanced we are
scientifically
so on top of that please understand
that all the clinical trials that were
necessary
were carried grouped out for all these
vaccines that you just listed
all the data has been publicly made
available and therefore
it is not accurate to say that this was
developed fast that corners were cut no
there were no corners cut
if anything all the people that have um
a role to play in the approval worked
hand in hand in the process to make it
as fast as possible
so i would like to say to people you
know what let's try and get society and
economy to solve diseases and healthcare
problems
looking at this as a paradigm of how we
can do things better rather than the
other way around
now separation right some reassuring
words
yes uh with regards to what could
possibly go wrong the point is that
those studies that were carried out
didn't show
that there is a anything untoward that
we need to be worried about apart from a
sore arm
maybe a bit of fever for a few days
which is
a sign that your immune system is
kicking in and it's doing what it's
supposed to do
so i wouldn't i wouldn't be worried too
much about
these observations the authorities are
doing the right thing
uh to make sure that nothing under what
is happening so we shouldn't worry too
much thank you very much
serial muscles for your reassuring words
serious mossos
is a molecular virologist joining us
there from the uk we appreciate your
time
you are welcome